Gina you give me hope as a petite woman
that I could still be a badass at life
are you kidding me yes
are you add the smaller we are the more
they you know they say that a lot of
power comes in small packages and that's
very true yeah okay because it's compact
you know what I'm saying yeah forget
that one yep Piper said that her first
scene filming this movie was with you
and she says she found you so
intimidating like just to be in a scene
with you how pretty you are
what was it like working with her oh I
loved working with Piper we have and I
we have one scene together and it was
pretty intense and it was the her first
scene this but I really had a good time
with her yeah what did you enjoy most
about doing this film um I think I just
really loved playing this kind of
character in these this high-stakes
situation yeah it been a long time you
know that that I've actually had a role
like this with this kind of intensity
and I really love the cast and loved the
director and I love the script so I just
had a good time and I got to come and
play and it was for a short period of
time I was in and out yeah it's perfect
Morgan seems I mean he seems pretty
presidential in real life absolutely he
is classy and smart I feel like he would
be a great guest for a red talk table he
would yeah I think he would be a great
guest I think Nick Nolte
I think Gerard I think Piper I think
really anybody who is willing to you
know as much as people call read table
talk a talk show it's really a
storytelling show so really the tables
for everybody anybody who comes to the
table in my opinion is deeply
interesting I love when people have the
courage to just share their story you
know so everybody has a great story to
share it's just a matter of the timing
of when you're ready to share it yeah
best part about working with Morgan and
Gerard um I think just you know Morgan
is a is an icon you know and just to be
part of a project with him and Gerard
Butler it's just a badass it's like you
know it was really a lot of fun having
the opportunity to to work with with
Jerry and be part of this project he's
such a great guy